[Music]
so I've been to Japan recently been to
Japan you haven't mentioned I've
mentioned there non-stop and you are
mocking me for this I want to play
dragon quest 11 echoes of an elusive
agent actually play it but got to see
loads of it and got to interview one of
the games the series is create a Yuji
Horii which we will be doing a video
with later on in a few weeks time which
you can look forward to on gamespot comm
and youtube.com forward slash GameSpot
what's very good very good in the
meantime I'm gonna talk to you briefly
about this game rights this you don't
have a lot of familiarity with Dragon
Quest but you are a JRPG and RPG fan yes
I am so I play a lot of Japanese games
for some reason I never never quite made
the leap and go into Dragon Quest I
think part of it is because this you
said this is what 11 yeah to me feels
like a commitment to a series that I
have no prior knowledge of and it feels
like I can't just jump in here that's
the thing you can well they need to yeah
it's really interesting because each one
is kind of like standalone in a lot of
ways there's themes that run through
them and there's ideas and concepts and
characters that appear in each one kind
of like final fantasy I was gonna say
see you yes this was Enix's final
fantasy before they merge with square
and it's basically the granddaddy of
JRPGs so like the first thing you notice
is it's it's look stunning and it's a
much bigger world so they've gone with a
new engine and that's allowed them to
create these massive environments and
although these environments are big and
there's a larger open world they're
interconnected environments so you have
these big spaces but you transition
between environments as you kind of
progress through the story and there's
about 88 of them and yeah there's a lot
of them and eventually you have the
freedom to go in between them as you
please
what's new for this game is they've
introduced a free camera mode okay so
these games are traditionally turn-based
and this game is like that but you've
got the option to switch it to a freak a
mode for people who like a little more
active you know kind of feel - it's very
similar to Nina to me in that respect so
it's like if you like to control the
camera used
what's great about that is though you
get a feeling of being actively involved
but you also get to like look at the
enemies but you get to see the classes
and they look better than ever
another new big thing for this version
the game is the exploration which you
just saw there there's a lot more
verticality to the world now and then
into kind of like meat that they've
introduced things like climbing and
running and sprinting and that kind of
stuff so it's easier to explore worlds
so you play as this character who's the
archetypal hero it's a very classical
Japanese story with this character it's
your 16th birthday you've just left a
little you know south southern town in
the in the mountains and you've realized
that you are the reincarnation of a hero
I realize that I'm the hero and everyone
goes oh you're the hero so your first
act is to go to meet the king and figure
out what that means for you so there is
still kind of like a how do I deal with
this yeah and the King kind of like when
you mean king carnelian and his boy -
yeah and his boy would be angry eyebrows
and sold there he kind of like welcomes
you with open arms he confirms that you
have the birthmark because every hero
has the birthmark to show that you're
the hero and then immediately turns on
you and that's where your journey begins
the the Kings reasoning is it's just
like light is intertwined with dark the
hero is intertwined with the dreadlord
of classic RPG fare and it's it's the
same kind of story that you get always
for in these types of games and
specifically in Dragon Quest and but
that's also just kind of like the
foundation for the exploration and the
couches you meet along the way so
following this like you get chucked in
the jail and you kind of break out and
then yeah you go on your journey and
along that journey you find different
people to to kind of meet up with and
you know take on this journey with you
and ultimately dispel evil and then
become the savior of the hero of the
world and all the savior of the hero of
the world of the greatness yes exactly
so one of the other big things that
you'll see introduced in this game is
they've made a bunch of tweaks that
makes it a little more palatable for
Westerners right they've introduced that
verticality and all that stuff when you
say verticality when you climb
is it like Zelda climbing or is it like
no it's a more perfect places you can
climb there's very specific patterns you
can climb and in their demo that we had
there was like you walk around town and
you get that thing with ambient dialogue
and then the certain characters will
give you side quests and another thing
that they do to encourage that is
they've introduced a first-person view
mode but yes sir it's very much this
games been out for a while in Japan and
like this is the western version of it
so they made it a little more palpable
by doing things like that they've
changed the menu so it's not like when
you see a pop-up it looks like it's on
written on a scroll and that's got like
whereas in Japan it's the classic black
on white text so that's a big big part
of that is localized yeah localized
fully fully like localize it's got full
cutscenes and it's got full lip-syncing
which is a big deal yes and yeah what
I'm excited about is the reason you play
these games is kind of like ninokuni
it's so charming
the world is so charming this is a great
year like for JRPGs as a whole and it's
been a great year two three years you
know for JRPGs between Final Fantasy
ninokuni just come out near persona like
it's and I think a lot of people are
going to be wanting more and this is a
good opportunity to play one of the best
series of all time when it comes to jail
it's an incredibly beloved series
chances are you may not have checked it
out because like with you Lucy it's the
11th one so that scares you I mean it
absolutely shouldn't I mean yeah but I
like this weird barrier to entry
but knowing now that its final finds the
Esk and that it's not really there are
thematic connections and stuff it makes
it a lot more palatable be interested to
see how well Square managed to
communicate that to people yeah I mean
they they haven't so far because it's
gone 11 on it but I feel like that's
what kind of what what this video this
is a preview of the game obviously so
we're yet to deliver our verdict on it
but like from what I've seen it seems
like a great jumping on point
it's got we briefly touched on it but
it's got like loads of characters it
doesn't have a job system anymore but
you can still you have these unique
characters that can spin be specialized
as skill trees and there
Actives that I love battle it's
beautiful charming I highly encourage
people to keep an eye on it at least
especially if you like JRPGs my dream is
that a lot of people see this game play
it and enjoy it if it's good and then go
back and play through the other games
because they are fantastic there's some
great horrible ones there's some great
console ones do me like a Minecraft ask
ya builders is really really fun in its
own switch Oh check that out as well but
yeah that's that's our brief but very
intense brief and intense
we like deliver our previews like we're
the Gilmore Girls
that's us thank you for watching this
video keep your eyes on games for calm
and youtube.com forward slash GameSpot
where we'll have more coverage of Dragon
Quest including that feature as well as
every other game because we're a video
game website in the meantime you can
find us on Twitter I'm at tomorrow H I'm
at least James games or I'm gonna change
my Twitter handle to some sort of
Gilmore Girls reference now and we'll
see you next time place and rehnquist
[Music]
[Music]